shut up
stop hitting
i'm just thinking it
check check test
well fake it's a clapper so i can see
the thing and then sync
it's one of these things you do to make
believe that you're doing something but
it's not anything it's
was it sea world seals
you could throw me a fish well if i had
a clapper if i just went like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what people are talking about
we're rolling i know we are it's the tim
dillon can you sit in your chair and do
the show where are you going i was
looking for my water your water
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show if we can even call it that
if everybody settled down our friends
devin uh acosta ida tavakoli join us uh
this evening
for the uh
broadcast
devon looks uh
completely out of it and then it looks
very poised she's sitting there very
poised like we're gonna have yeah i'm
gonna really
you know really get into it yeah here
are the issues of the day
greg norman golfer ben's friend says uh
we all make mistakes regarding jamal
khashoggi's murder tell us everybody
quickly what's going on with
the saudi because saudis own everything
now they own a stake in live nation
they own free speech
they own a lot of the great real estate
in america now they also somehow have
gotten golf yeah yeah the saudis own
golf now they can have it live yes live
golf so that's what i say so for anyone
that doesn't know greg norman was a huge
golfer in the 80s in the 90s the shark
from australia australia right
and uh so they gave him a war chest of
about 350 million dollars to get as many
players over to the pga tour
from the pga tour to the saudi tour
which is going to take place in the u.s
what's the saudi tour called live golf
l-i-v golf they love like names like
that
live golf
so this organization it's a fun of saudi
arabia arabia they're going to get
people from the pga tour to play in
these events it looks like they got phil
mickelson with like 40 million dollars
to cross season all kinds of gambling
debts he needs help that's the rumor is
he owes people tons and like millions of
dollars it's always been a rumor he had
huge problems with gambling but
supposedly he's doing this to get uh he
owed bones makai his caddy hundreds of
thousands get two in the weeds because
no one cares except you about golf no
one cares bones makai well he does he
does this no one gives a [ __ ] and he
keeps i want broad strokes to just we
can understand what's happening so
so uh so he's getting players from the
pga tour over to the saudi tour if they
go to the saudi tour they are banned
from the pga tour interesting and he's
getting big players with uh
money again
right
and so now they keep asking them about
saudi arabia they keep going hey don't
you
you know what about the human rights
violations and he basically says things
like
what are you gonna do
and so they asked him about
so ahead of the group's inaugural event
said for june 9 11. september 11th
not september 11th june
9 11. but what does that mean june 9th
through the 11th june 9th through the
11th odd
the first saudi golf tournament
is the 9th through the 11th of june
that's odd
at centurion golf club outside of london
norman was asked his thoughts on saudi
arabia's involvement in the 2018 murder
of washington post reporter and united
states resident jamal khashoggi
quote from what i heard and what you
guys reported norman said
just take ownership of what it is take
ownership no matter what it is look
we've all made mistakes
and you just want to learn from those
mistakes and how you can correct them
going forward
he's so terrified because he'll kill him
so he's like we all make mistakes ev we
all
have a guy captured and tortured on
closed circuit television while we
instruct the captures how exactly to
torture him we've all made mistakes
mulligan
and greg norman is his job now is just
to defend the saudi human rights record
uh which by the way thank god america
set up that labyrinth of secret torture
prisons
during uh the iraq and afghanistan war
so you could he could really just kind
of point to that big hey man
there was a lot of people that we
tortured that probably had nothing to do
with anything
so thank god uh we've our moral
authority's diminished but i would this
is a big thing for you because you
really like golf they're breaking up the
pga tour uh phil might not defend his
title this year uh but all right shut up
but this is
he's really into he likes golf you know
what i mean it's like i used to be a
swimmer he used to be a golfer
how insane would it be if i still cared
about swimming
lessons i was a really good swimmer when
i was eight
yeah but but then there's the olympics
there's there's there's some uh you know
spirit around swimming i think in this
country there's not no i mean every four
years
i mean there's a spirit around maybe the
olympics but yeah that's what i mean it
would be insane yes if i was cared
about swimming i haven't done it
competitively in years
and but i i love ben's passion for it
but it's just a little absurd
and it gets to a point where it's it's
disgusting
i find it endearing he's yeah how much
is yo bones makai hundreds of thousands
who cares
[Laughter]
dude these names he comes up with
are [ __ ] why i think he makes them up
you didn't make that up no it's adam
bones mccoy he's in a golf announcer now
he retired from caddying for phil and
people thought he wanted to be a
broadcaster turns out he just was i
guess was owed a bunch of money from
phil so what do you think mickelson does
he goes uh to the casino and gets really
wacky no he plays he plays golf with
like jordan and guys like that and just
does massive bets
and loses
isn't he professional isn't that the
whole point no because he runs on
adrenaline he probably goes oh for a
million bucks i'll hit it over this tree
and slice it onto the green like he does
dumb [ __ ] like that yeah he's like
gambling well he deserves to be in a
[ __ ] debtor's prison
if he's doing [ __ ] like that like let me
watch me bounce it off a rock a million
bucks
if he's doing stupid [ __ ]
i thought at least he was like if we if
i win i get like and he's doing crazy
like carnival acts on a god of course
for money what kind of sick [ __ ]
is this guy
he's very eccentric
for sure
uh well we wish the best we are big fans
of saudis here i love them i love a
culture of
rich people who smoke and a culture of
quiet women
and i've never in the world been around
saudi women and went oh my god will they
shut up
it's never happened they are a quiet
uh group of women
and i'm also everyone's like oh they're
being abused with the thing i'm like you
know what i i don't think so they seem
happy and i'm not bothered by it
if so let's stop going around the world
telling everybody how they're being
abused and because all we do in this
country is tell people how they're not
being abused
they go well they can't take off their
thing
the abaya or the burqa whatever it's
called
although women in saudi arabia can apply
for drivers driving licenses without
needing permission from a male guardian
they still need that permission to
travel abroad and that is fine
that's absolutely fine
i mean ida what is your issue with that
you're a modern arab woman
yeah uh i mean i'm iranian so there's a
i think there's a little like beef with
arabs and persians um
why i don't i mean listen i don't mind
this it's all the same to me
yeah y'all eat hummus i mean listen i
live in america so it's practically all
the same to me too when's the last time
you were in iran oh god when i was six
or seven oh so you don't remember
anything no i remember it i remember
i remember as much as i need to remember
right to be an american yeah
no i'm kidding i'm very i like uh the
iranian culture i don't mind the saudis
staying there if that's what they
choose to do i don't think they have any
choice but uh yeah i have no opinion one
way or the other
here's my thing
is it oppressive to the women
there's an argument to be made that
being that having to ask for permission
to travel is oppressive yeah there's
also an argument to be made that it's a
better
way to do it
you know what i mean if you're a man
this saudi arabia is a wonderland
oh that sounds incredible yeah it's like
sam talent i don't want to give away his
joke but he has such a great joke where
because blank is for the boys he goes
you know
oh yeah muslim heavens for the boys yeah
he has such a great joke that we've now
given away but the point is
i think whatever he's done it a bunch uh
you know the reality is i don't get
involved i don't tell people what to do
in my own country and i don't tell
people what to do in saudi arabia and if
the women are not into it over there
they can you know you do it they can do
another thing they can do another thing
but
yeah
you know i don't i'm not like one of
these guys who's like you got to do it
like we do it
do it like you do it but i'm very big
fans of the saudis um and i think and
and i i really like what they've done
for beverly hills
and no truly and i like just the kind of
vibe i like the vibe of beverly hills i
like the big rolls-royces and the bling
and a lot of that's very persian but i i
like that
i like that and it's for me
and uh so we wish them well and i hope
this live golf thing is good and i hope
that it's [ __ ] blinged out like i
hope it's like saudi style like the
caddies you said maybe they'd be like
little pink rolls royces
and i just hope that it is [ __ ]
awesome i hope it's not like this waspy
boring sport that you know who cares i
want it to be really really cool again
yeah they're very gaudy they're daunting
ostentatious like they're they're very
in your face but um the women enjoy none
of that i think uh
well we don't know what they're enjoying
that's the great thing about the culture
it's a mystery yeah yeah they could
really be having fun you're right the
other thing is they might be having more
fun than we know it might be fun to be
covered all the time you're in your own
little world and you're giggling yeah
and you're laughing with your friends
just ask for permission to have fun
who needs to travel abroad first of all
i mean can you imagine like
who nee can you imagine american women
figuring out a good reason to travel
abroad why do you want to go abroad get
drunk in your yard you're not going to
learn anything american women aren't
going abroad to learn things they're
going to get [ __ ] up and accuse some
poor sailor a rape
now
i got to talk about this podcast because
i you know me i every now and then i
find something i just can't stop
watching
and i mean i've only showed you a few
minutes of this but it is the greatest
thing i've ever seen in my life i can't
believe it even exists it is the most la
thing i've ever seen i like these people
i don't know them but they're they're
they're fun
and this is not a knock on them at all
this is the most la
thing i have ever watched in my life
these are three influencers trying to
explain kind of what an influencer is
yeah and what an influencer does
it's very interesting to watch this
and it makes me laugh
hard in a world where nothing does
anymore
this really entertains me
because it's kind of i don't know if
it's a genuine
or if it's kind of a character or if
it's half genuine or half character it's
hard to know
but all i know here's where i stop it's
entertaining
very
entertaining this show
that i watch
uh and and i watched their breakdown of
the russia thing which was brilliant it
was oh really well they didn't know
where russia was
they didn't know what it was
and they didn't know what the ukraine
was
and it was such a refreshing perspective
versus everyone on twitter who's like an
expert in foreign policy in their own
heads these people
were brave enough to go i don't know
what that is
what is the ukraine
let's start there because by the way
that's a better system
in terms of figuring out what's going on
in the world to just start at ground
zero and go what is russia
go
i want to watch this little clip these
are three influencers explaining what it
is
to be an influencer it is truly one of
the greatest things i've ever seen
recommend it highly it's hard to avoid
the question yeah yeah like
okay okay let's see someone says someone
hasn't asked me that in so long also so
that should
um
i'll just be like i don't know i'm just
like a lazy piece of [ __ ] and then i ran
away yeah
i don't i never i like it goes back and
forth between like i work in social
media which does which is not
like that doesn't make sense yeah
you do
yeah but like i feel like when you say
like i work in social media people are
thinking like behind the scenes like you
work for instagram oh kinda i don't know
but
i don't i know i mean
yeah well i mean i turn around
what do you do right yeah you just i lie
i basically lie
um
but what was it gonna say oh i say i do
consulting and then no one ever asks
another question right you could you
could you could because everybody
consults
you know like
you can talk
i guess in a way actually what does
consulting mean it means to offer your
services was that for a minute or advice
it's just
great it's informative what is
consulting
it's a great she the woman asked the
question hey what is what is that i
hadn't thought about that in a while
this is what's great about these people
they're unashamed to just go what is
console i don't know what it is
i hear it
people do it
but i don't know what it is they're just
pure salt of the earth it's just
kind of amazing
here and watch this because now they
they credit the one and that these two
credit the one in the middle for i
believe inventing comedy on the internet
they
credit her for investing
no i'm not kidding around the the next
thing is they credit uh this woman in
the middle
for starting
comedy on the internet
i swear to god during the pandemic it's
breathtaking
i can't
i'm telling you right now
if this
is scripted
it is brilliant
or even if it's not scripted if it's
loosely verite style kirby enthusiast i
don't know what this is i don't know if
they know what it is but i'm telling you
right now and i don't know any of you
you are doing the greatest level of
satire that maybe has been done in the
last decade i don't know if you know
what you're doing
but god don't stop please don't stop
let's go
in one way or another he's not a
consultant i said i used to say i work
in advertising because i thought like
okay with brands marketing marketing
advertising that checks out to me that
makes complete sense people would ask me
more about like what agency and then
well then if you think about mute we're
writers directors yeah we are editors
edit producers
we're writers directors editors
producers
where we're
entrepreneurs yeah
we're on tours yeah we're venture
capitalists
i mean we're writers we're directors
we're producers and again no shade to
anybody here but literally they're going
like this
scent
that's kind of what it is right right
are you like stuffing cheerios in their
mouth and like farting and
and then hitting send like but she's
going for writers we're directors we're
producers
she said she hadn't left her bed in like
a month yeah she's making it all from a
bed she's like from a bed she's a writer
a director a producer and she's a gaffer
she's the terence malek of tickets she's
the martin scorsese it's amazing
she's like when you think about it
it's great she goes when you think about
it it's all in the words because when
you think about it we're writers
directors
actors produce first of all
give them give them give them
give them writers oddly
give them
actors
okay even maybe give them directors
producers
they're producing
i guess they're producing the whole
yeah i don't know they're not making a
bunch of calls and organizing i don't
know but what's great is that they've
we've already established they don't
really know what words mean they go
what's a consultant so they don't know
what words really mean
and that's what makes it so good because
people that know what words mean are
boring i truly believe this and mean
this you're right when you don't know
what words mean you're anything
you know she's like i'm an invertebrate
zoologist
i'm a writer i'm an actress i'm an
astronaut and they go what is and she
goes oh what is an astronaut and they go
i think it's someone that like goes to
other planets and she goes oh
oh maybe i'm not that like so they don't
they have to like reverse engineer right
so let's now this is my favorite part
where these guys
uh tell this woman in the front in the
middle that she started
they basically call her the charlie
chaplin no she's internet comedy she
started comedy on the internet which his
side was unaware and i'm sure she's a
lovely woman but again it's this is the
it's the best show on here it's funnier
than my show it is funny it is not even
close it is not even a contest of how
better this is than what i do
we are our own agents yeah managers do
you guys like what we're doing so far
[Laughter]
do your parents do your parents feel
like we obviously like make videos
courtney i don't know if we said average
fashion blogger yeah better known online
as average fashion blogger we have her
in today it's one of our good friends
but
like
let's break it down do your parents get
what you do
my parents yeah my dad's been obsessed
he like
he does it less now um but in the
beginning he like always called me like
i have a really really good viral video
for you yeah and they would say like the
most problematic thing in the world but
he like he gets it he like wants to do
it so bad i feel like you are really
like the blueprint you started off
that's really dramatic no i i really
mean that with my whole heart like you
you started making comedic videos on
instagram i can't really think of
anyone that did it i think anyone that
made videos period before tick-tock
right
he goes i can't think of anyone that
made videos hold on roll that one back
because i can't think of anyone that
made videos before take like
it's a joke
you started making comedic videos on
instagram i can't really think of he's
kidding anyone that did it i think
anyone that made videos period before
tick tock right was the blueprint
yeah yeah okay um now you're about to
hit a million on tech talk she already
babe i already did
i mean it's brilliant in a way um it's
brilliant in a way
because you have three people that are
influencers are trying to be influencers
you know whatever that means
trying to explain what it is
figuring out that it's kind of hard to
explain
with words
and
you know they're just kind of it's just
it's la this is la these are people are
just floating around
yeah in in
in in and out of reality
they're all like 14 years old they're
very young but they're not the other
thing is i don't know if they're 14 or
if they're like 40. i think they look
for their no one knows yeah they're
supposed to look young they're supposed
to look i think they're supposed to
exude like a pre-pubescent yeah the
whole thing's like it's cartoonish it's
like fun and it's like we're hanging out
like hanging out we're like
hang out like you are like
like you're like a friend of ours like
you like
like remember that i met you like i met
you like
in a car
we we're in a car what's a car
yeah so like
it's a it's a like it's like a spaceship
on the ground
and
and like remember coachella is like
really funny because like you were like
and and i was there and like we didn't
even know that we like we like knew each
other from like social media but like we
didn't like we didn't know
each other
and then every now and then the brook
one will come in and she'll be like my
grandmother was in the holocaust
like out of nowhere and i'm like this is
the greatest show that's ever been done
no
[Music]
and she'll be like but she survived
and then she'll be like was dozie cat
good
coachella
did you enjoy dojicat
anyway
super fan of this show no it's lit
literally and my first show that i love
the ww bro podcast was about a guy who
was 600 pounds and gave diet advice yes
nothing better yeah and he would be
great because he would come on and he
would go like he'd go thanksgiving i
take the day off he goes thanksgiving i
eat
and it was so beautiful
there's nothing like the feeling of
getting outside to run ride hike or just
be somewhere we feel the most ourselves
every man jack puts that experience in a
bottle their men's care products feature
naturally derived ingredients outdoor
inspired scents and responsible
packaging so you could take the
inspiration of the great outdoors
wherever you roam
i
how great is it to smell and feel like
nature
i love it it's amazing we spent a lot of
time thinking about what we put in our
bodies but what you put on your body is
just as important that neo-green goop
being sold as body wash is anything but
natural or clean besides if you need a
phd to pronounce it do you really want
it hanging out on your skin
every man jack's care products use the
best ingredients nature has to offer
it's amazing smell like the ocean the
woods
smell like a cedar fire that's roaring
in a cabin
from body wash deodorant and skin care
products to shampoos bombs and oils to
tame and nourish your hair and beard
make every day feel like a getaway with
incredible scents inspired by the great
outdoors sandalwood cedarwood sea salt
citrus
they use many clean naturally derived
ingredients as possible like activated
charcoal caffeine green tea coconut oil
shea butter every man jack also makes a
great gift for all the guys in your life
and now is the perfect time
i'm telling you
head to everymanjack.com and get 20 off
your first purchase with the code dylan
d-i-l-l-o-n
go to
everymanjack.com to get 20 off your
first purchase with the code dylan
d-i-l-l-o-n
i love this i've used it i'm telling you
right now i love nature and to be part
of nature without having to be in it is
absolutely amazing oh yeah i love the
citrus the sea salt every man jack works
exceptionally without any of the harsh
chemicals like parabens or dyes it can
be abrasive to your skin and leave it
feeling dry they use as many clean
naturally derived ingredients as
possible you know those times when
you're so into what you're doing that
you can't think about anything else at
times when you're you're most focused
and productive psychologists call it the
feeling of being in the flow state
alpha brain from on it is the ultimate
way to get there a world-renowned
nootropic supplement with over 1 million
bottles sold alpha brain promotes
cognitive functions including memory
mental speed and focus
it can help you remember names zero in
on complex tasks and think more clearly
under stress comedian and podcaster joe
rogan says he feels that it helps him
form better sentences when he's talking
alpha brain contains amino acids and
plant plant
compounds
buying plant
i should take alpha brain
plant compounds that promote the brain's
release of alpha waves
which are associated with greater
creativity and productivity at the same
time it supports neurotransmitters
chemicals that relay
in and from the brain if coffee and
energy drinks make you jittery you can
rest easy knowing that alpha brain is a
caffeine free
alternative but if for any reason you
don't like alpha brain you can get your
money back
just give us two weeks if at any point
you don't feel like it is working for
you just tell us why
save ten percent on your order by going
to
onit.comtimtim that's on it.com tim tim
uh i love it it's a daily nootropic it
promotes all the things you need you
need to be focused you need
concentration you need your cognitive
functions functioning you need memory
you got to get into that flow state you
got to be in the zone it sold over half
a million bottles and has a money back
guarantee so at the end of the day
hey what's the problem right
buy it
now
i like alpha brain and everyone uses it
boeing 737 jet carrying 160 people
aboard takeoff in israel after
pranksters used iphone airdrop to send
terrified passengers pictures of plane
crashes causing one woman to feign
and so in response this is such a crazy
story and in response to this israel
bombed a palestinian nursery school
which i thought was a very proportional
and appropriate response to just
now this is a ballsy thing to do
plain pranks i mean not even nelk has
done this
plane pranks right now are ballsy
yeah when's the last time you've heard
of somebody getting up to mischief on a
plane
this is harmless it is
it's not like a bomb threat exactly and
it's fine but it might be it might make
i i agree with you i do think it's funny
and i recommend people do it
i'm telling people to do it but people
might look at those airdrop photos and
go oh this plane's gonna crash because
this might be a like a fun way to let us
know well i mean
what are they interesting
the people
are they're reading the feud like they
they could see into the future they're
sending them a shot of the future well
imagine this you're on a plane you get
an airdrop and it's a bunch of plane
crash photos would it might not be a way
of somebody on the plane going hey
things are about to get rocky well was
it sent by by a saudi arabian i mean if
not right then
it's fine well we don't know who is sent
by
i mean it seems harmless to me what now
what happened to these good people ben i
believe they were arrested uh their nine
suspects described by israeli nelq
that's kriev will do it
eve will do it
air drop the button
here i dropped a bunch of plane crash
photos
that shule will do it
shmoo will do it i'm trying to make this
bit work
it's small we'll do it
funny
like like remember when like i'm like
you were like
like standing in a crowd
and like you look at me and then i like
looked at you but then you looked away
you remember that and i was like oh you
don't like me and that was like weird so
like we started weird but then like i
realized that like i like didn't know
where i was
because i had a gummy bear full of acid
in the port-a-potty
and i was being led around kind of like
a baby
and then i had this realization that
like a lot of what i do stems from this
like deep
inner loneliness and search for meaning
and it was [ __ ]
wild
and then we saw a ton of mojo
um
i don't know why they did this but i
think it's funny i think kids need to
have fun people need to have fun right
now and it's such a tense time
with everything that's happening around
the world oh you know what is this
another picture showing a person on top
of a jet engine believed to have been
sent
using the air but this is funny so it
makes people think maybe this is going
on on their pla but who knows right
it's it's meant to confuse is what i
imagine right
yeah i mean what i mean what are they
insinuating that this is going to happen
on the on the plan i think they wanted
people to maybe feel it's just meant to
scare people hold on troubled actor andy
dick is arrested for felony sexual
battery at california trailer park
what's going on
he assaulted someone sexually i heard
yeah there it is uh trouble doctor andy
dick is arrested at his california
trailer park is he living in a trailer
park now
yeah man comedy it's just a it's a great
life
uh he arrested for sexually assaulting
another man after arrest for hitting
boyfriend with the bottle and frying pan
andy dick 56 was hold off in handcuffs
after police arrested him for felony
sexual battery after an adult male
claimed the comedian sexually assaulted
him deputies swarmed his trailer god i
mean imagine an article being written
about you where one of the quotes was
deputies swarmed his trailer
rough
they could reportedly be living in an rv
with a group of live streamers
god
jesus christ
i he wasn't on the radar for a bit this
is one of the many arrests that the
comedian has had who's been transparent
about his uh history of alcohol and drug
abuse by the way it's not his choice to
be transparent like it's pretty much out
in the o i love how they're like he's
been transparent about this
i'm like yeah lizzo's been transparent
about her weight it's like yeah has she
it was a real it was a real mystery to
everybody
uh police from the orange county
sheriff's department swarms his modest
trailer is they gotta knock it they
gotta knock a trailer down man they're
gonna say his trailers modest
dressed in a gray hoodie and black jaw
guys
dick was hold away in handcuffs before
being placed inside a patrol car i mean
this is unfortunate
during the police ambush sheriff's
deputies were seeing android dick's
trailer and searching it after he was
placed into custody ah cause he's like
hitting people with pants and stuff
this is really unfortunate uh this man
has problems with drugs and alcohol
and he's in a trailer and there's a
better video of it there's a video of a
live stream they did where his roommate
pulled a gun on someone that was coming
to their trailer yeah get that well you
know you would think a producer would
have something like that ready or done
in show research but this he's too
worried about the saudi arabians taking
over golf
to really do the show prep
they're a real threat right i understand
yeah no because he's home with his wife
i work so hard i go to australia i go to
australia
he's a demon why did he make you go
why would he make you work
here's a stream here oh this looks good
don't [ __ ] with me dude
get
don't shoot the gun this is this is like
the end of boogie nights
i mean look at andy i feel bad man he's
on a cot
in a trailer that by the way looks fine
yeah it looks big is that is that a
modest trailer that looks great looks
like an apartment in glendale yeah i'm
wondering if that's even the trailer i
mean maybe it is
so now he's just taking money on paypal
and the cameo
god and this is this is a story we kind
of stumbled upon by accident he's laying
on a cot
a guy screaming at another girl with a
gun andy dicks just kind of laying there
unaffected like it's just a regular day
he's like don't shoot the gun
please don't shoot the gun
don't shoot the gun not even don't kill
the guy it's like andy dick's like just
don't shoot the gun
let's see how this finishes
oh [ __ ] don't come back here dude
don't do it
you better call me before you do don't
show up you're uninvited i swear to
[ __ ] guy
jesus
who is that guy
he's another extorter i do
you're so protective it really makes you
describe i'm sorry dude
you're so protective it really makes me
cry he's like this is a beautiful moment
for us
you're so protective you treat me so
well in this trailer
you treat me so well it makes me cry
you're just so goddamn romantic it makes
me cry don't shoot the gun
well is that his boyfriend that is kind
of lovely
it's sweet it is kind of sweet right i
mean
yeah
if you two are living in a trailer and
then extorter whatever that means
somebody trying to extort
devin would use me as a as a shield yeah
no no
there would be no
[ __ ] never like be a fight player
chivalry there no no no no
um
but i hope that uh
he gets it together right he was on
dancing with the stars right recently no
god no but that was years ago usually
that shows a fall from grace so if
you're if i mean and then this wasn't he
on celebrity rehab
he kind of looks like dr drew like when
that was a thing i think he was on
celebrity rehab
but maybe he wasn't yeah with like tom
size more and like i thought he was here
we go tim yeah he was here okay he was
on sober house there what is that this
was their like
spin-off this girl jennifer was like the
head sobriety person
and using season one this is when they
were literally just
like completely using drug addicts for
viewers
and putting them in like very unserious
it was like a very unserious attempt to
cure any of them yeah and you had like
jeff conaway
and
uh eric roberts yeah stephen adler there
was a bunch of people here
dr drew the guy who used to play hobie
on baywatch with the young kid hobie he
grew up i forget what his name was was
it jeremy jackson
the guy who was hobie on baywatch and he
was like uh
he was talking about all the steroids he
uses
and he was like uh
he goes yeah he goes
this is uh a bull a a bull uh whatever
hormone pre-slaughter like he was like
pre-slaughter like before there's like
and he would like inject himself but i
believe he was
yeah i believe he was on their show and
this is the other thing with doing a
podcast i'm either right or i'm
slandering someone
you know what i mean
i'm either no it's jeremy jackson i
think just type in jeremy jackson's
celebrity rehab
i mean it really you're dealing with
here okay yeah that's what i thought
oh it's rough
oh yeah i mean he had a steroid thing
wasn't heidi fleisch on there yes heidi
fletch i believe was on there
mackenzie uh
the heard the mamas and the papa
phillips yes
yeah i think a bunch of people were on
there and it was uh you know they were
just trying
god why do i know all this they were
trying to get a lot of views
you know and it was just you know
how many by the way here's a great
question have any of those people
sobered up like has anybody on celebrity
rehab ever sobered up
he's sober up there's no show the
producers probably throw them pills
throughout filming there's a little
there's a little uh
there's a little surprise in your
dressing room
i'll see you at three there's a mint on
your pillow yeah so i i think that uh
yeah where are the stars from celebrity
rehab now i'm sure this will be a real
treat
this would be a real pick-me-up in a
grave
dr drew got grew tired of taking all the
heat yeah cause you're killing people
keep going
what is he what's his she's showing your
mom's house what does he do he was like
the biggest guy on cnn too what does he
do on your mom's house uh it's uh
late late night after dark with dr drew
or whatever and he just like talks to
people about their problems okay it's
like the old show yeah uh
uh this is carrie ann panish yeah she
said she's a she came out on top um
uh so yeah it looks like she did good
okay i don't know what that means go up
let's see one
let's see what hold on
according to nbc gawker published a tape
of new shenanigans between panish eric
dane and his wife rebecca gerhart in
2009
uh
panish accused her celebrity rehab
castmate mindy mccready releasing the
tape while penis was still using math in
2012.
she has since gotten sober kept her
family intact started a design business
okay
tom sizemore to mass we're not even
going to read it it's just a big mess
you know
heidi flick get out of here hiding flies
that's a big mess
we're not even gonna dignify that okay
mike star battled multiple demons he
looks like the guy in the trailer with
andy dick yeah
he died of an overdose good job dr phil
mindy mccready uh personal tragedy was
devastating she died by suicide so i
mean these are all these are the people
that we're at celebrity rehab
[Music]
seth shifty sherlock binser isn't giving
up
good for him no one knows rajit nielsen
she started dating flava flav
that's good wasn't that her sobriety
that wasn't that how her
yeah all right we're not we're not going
to go through all of them but yeah that
was like a massive show where just
nobody that was what reality tv was when
i was growing up no but like they took
really people that were in a lot of pain
and did not give them help
on television week after week yeah you
watch their conditions degenerate they
would attack each other
they would destroy their lives and there
was a film crew to follow it that was
reality television before the genre that
we have now which was like
rich [ __ ] tv
which was like we find wealthy people
that have more money than you and they
shove it down your throat in a very
like grotesque way and you just have to
sit there and take it not only will you
take it but you'll like it
you'll like it when these [ __ ] go
i buy a house for each one of my kids
isn't that what everybody does
go to the original real housewives of
orange county which by the way the
season one is still the best
cultural depiction of the mortgage
crisis because everybody on the show is
mentally [ __ ] and they all own like
five houses and you go how did this
happen i mean literally one guy has like
a brain neurological injury this
baseball player from orange county and
he's just like he's like booze like
dribbling out of his mouth and the
wife's a big realtor and she's a big
fatty boom baddie and uh if you can go
to season one of the real housewives of
orange county the opening sequence okay
and the opening sequence is going to
show you the all these women have these
tag lines
and this was like
when reality tv shifted from like we'll
put everyone in a house we'll get him
drunk let's get him [ __ ] up and see
what happens and then reality tv kind of
shifted and became like hey
there's people out there that are doing
a hell of a lot better than you
that's what reality tv became which is
kind of still what it is
except now it's weird now it's like
everyone's singing there's like nine
shows about karaoke it's like the mask
singer and then there's a new show
called don't forget the lyrics
and there's another show about whether
the singer's bad or good or lip-syncing
or are you lips lips and battle and
who's
everybody now
people are so stupid in this country
they can only handle that because
they've been so traumatized by the
genres of reality tv that came before
them like watch this person die of a
heroin overdose in slow-mo and watch
this rich family parade their wealth
around now all people can handle is
staring at the tv and watching like a
celebrity sing
like uh the song from titanic poorly
like to get and they're like wait a
minute
are you gonna forget the lyrics and
they're like near far
wherever you are
i am
and the people at home are like she's
gonna forget the lyrics
she doesn't know it
i could see my drunk aunt sitting there
being like she doesn't know it she
doesn't so that's all we can handle
right now is watching people sing
i've always hated karaoke i despised it
i hate when drunk people get up in long
island bars and they're like you know
they're like [ __ ] like and they get
into it there's nothing worse there's
somebody into it a karaoke you know
[Music]
people are just like at the bar like
what the [ __ ] is wrong and that's all
reality tv so ken jong host i can see
your voice a new guessing game on fox
where literally they bring people we
don't even know me and ben tried to
watch this show
and we didn't even know we couldn't
follow it and we're reasonably
intelligent
what it is
let's try to explain can we explain okay
fake it till you make it that's
basically the concept of the new
competition series quote i can see your
voice contestants and celebrities have
to figure out who's actually a good
singer without hearing their real voice
what are we doing
think about that again contestants
have to figure out who's a good singer
without hearing their real voice so they
come out they lip-sync to something and
you have to decide if they're
lip-syncing to their own voice
that's good or someone else's voice and
their voice is horrible but you pick two
people and you pick you and they kind of
go at each other and you go like
oh
which one has the real good voice
and this is all intellectually that
people can handle right now like all
they can handle is watching people sing
like it's like a talent show we've gone
back to the basics here where it's just
it's a big [ __ ] up talent show some
people are talented and some people are
and by the way it doesn't really matter
none of these people get deals
bad voice good voice right what do they
get ten thousand dollars oh it says a
hundred grand 100 grand after taxis
everything like that i mean it's like
this isn't you know it's not like
american idol now you're going to
hollywood this is like i would stand up
as an audience member go does it really
matter
whose voice is good or bad
they're not they're both 40.
they're not gonna be christina aguilera
who cares whose voice is good or bad
it's the crazy thing but what this is
fun watch the real housewife
okay so it starts where it goes seven
million families live in gated
communities so now remember this
uh debuts when in 2005 this is like the
height of
fake business all over america this
debuts people
are like
up they're in debt to their eyeballs
they're all in sham mortgages they're
all living way beyond their means and
it's all about to collapse it's on the
brink of collapsing and then this is
what they put out and here play this
i don't wanna get old
[Music]
he's pretty much keeping me
[Music]
are the police involved
[Music]
it's just money and you can't take it
with you
85 of the women around here have had
breast implants
yeah so it's like it's just it's just
it's just money you can't take it with
you and it's just through shots of like
women getting their tits done and
getting diamond necklaces and they're
like seven million people live in gated
communities and that that's really like
that's the genre of reality tv
that
we
we had for a while
we still have no i yeah it's it's it's
bet it culminated in like selling sunset
which is kind of a brilliant show
because adam develop the guy who did it
he's a genius he like did the hills and
he makes these shows like the scene is
selling sunset which we can't play with
i wish we could where where
adnan the real estate developer is like
and they're these cold like nordic types
and they're telling us this hopeless
zero davina who can't sell anything
and the woman looks at her goes please
make a deal and just the way it's
brilliantly shot you see like the cat
sleeping the dogs are sleeping
um but yeah that that's really where
reality tv is now it's like people are
just singing it's very infantile now
it's right we can't take anything it's
very silly it's like infant and it's
like the aha moments aren't even real
anymore and they don't matter it isn't
like the reveal doesn't matter there
used to be i used to watch old real
world and it's like people just beating
the living [ __ ] out of
each other the cops aren't called
real world hawaii with ruthie she's like
vomiting yeah it was insane no portland
now it's like these these reveals don't
mean anything they're like oh she wasn't
a good singer we got tricked i'm like
well if you think that's bad don't look
into 911
because you're gonna have a real how
about we do the mask defense secretary
and we find out where the tape is of the
plane hitting the pentagon
how about we do that on fox
next on fox the masked cia agent who's
telling the truth and who's not we have
two government whistleblowers and they
both come out
with uh something they're blowing a
whistle on and you have to decide what's
true and what's not you know like one
comes out and goes the government uh
participates in human trafficking rings
to compromise politicians and everyone
goes man i don't know and then the next
person comes out and they're like the
government murdered john f kennedy in
our in a coup
and you're like god who's
which masked government whistleblower is
correct here is it and then the reveals
it's both
and everyone's like [ __ ]
hosted by neil patrick harris yeah neil
patrick howard just to make a peppy
just peppy and fun
but that's like what
that's what we can handle now
uh is just watching people
sing we're hearing about crypto
everywhere crypto companies are
investing in stars like tom brady and
lebron james they even dominated the
super bowl ad spending millions to get
in front of sports fans but some of
these companies had their websites crash
on the big day or have poorly rated
customer service meanwhile exodus is
invested in making easy to use crypto
apps that have a built-in world-class
customer support team and if you don't
even have to submit personal details
like your mom's made name to use it just
download exodus and you're all set did
you hear about canada authorizing
financial institutions to freeze
people's accounts were suspected of
supporting protesting vaccine mandates
you don't even have to prove anything if
your money your crypto is being held by
a bank or exchange it's not really yours
if you can't spend it how you want get
your money under your control by holding
it in the crypto wallet like exodus no
sign up required and your funds cannot
be frozen inflation is insane right now
things are getting more expensive wages
aren't going up the government keeps
printing money to give away to people
who already have a lot of it the
traditional financial system is sinking
and bitcoin is a life raft it's time to
ditch your bank leave traditional
finance behind and join the financial
revolution exodus is a crypto app for
your phone and computer that is easy to
use supports over 150 crypto assets
looks great and has world-class customer
support i'm telling you right now a lot
of people are down on crypto right now
because you know it's um it's uh
collapsing
that being said it's clearly gonna be
here to stay
it's here to stay
so enough
with the mouth all the time
over four million people trust exodus to
manage their crypto join the movement
away from traditional finance by
downloading exodus visit exodus.com tim
to get started that's exodus.com tim to
get started it's a crypto wallet for
everyone i've got one ben's got one no
sign up is required download and if
you're ready to go by visiting
exodus.com t-i-m
it's great you can store your nfts
manage your portfolio and uh over four
million people trust it thank you get
started for free by downloading exodus
on mobile and desktop at exodus.com tim
i'm i'm telling you right now
have you ever tried athletic greens oh
yeah oh my god what is this stuff
i'm asking you oh it's a it's really
like a lifestyle i think it's whether
you eat keto paleo vegan or dairy free
or gluten-free
contains less than one gram of sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals or artificial
anything while still tasting good
supports better sleep quality and
recovery supports mental clarity and
alertness it's the one thing with the
best things athletic queens uses the
best of the best products based on the
latest science uh with constant product
iterations and third-party testing it
costs you less than three dollars a day
i mean you gotta invest in your own
health right oh yeah it's got over seven
thousand five star reviews it's
recommended by professional athletes
it's trusted by leading health experts
such as tim ferriss and michael gervais
it was created when the founder
experienced a ton of gut health issues
and ended up on a complicated supplement
routine to recover cost him 100 a day he
created athletic greens after
experiencing how difficult it was to
create an optimal nutritional routine on
your own it's a climate neutral
certified company in 2020 athletic
greens purchase carbon credits uh to
support projects protecting old-growth
rainforest for every purchase they
donate to organizations helping to get
nutritious food to kids in need
including no kid hungry here in the u.s
in 2020 athletic koreans donated 1.2
million meals to kids how cool is that
it's awesome
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamins d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit
athleticgreens.com tim dillon again
that's athleticgreens.com
tim dillon to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimately the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's one
scoop of in a cup of water every day
that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health this is a beautiful
story we kind of want to wrap things up
on this there's a there was this was a
uh manhunt
this is uh
this is a tale as old as time a
corrections officer falls in love with a
inmate
they escape together this is one of the
old the only american real love stories
we have left you know
there's a few
love stories we have left
in this country
you know what i mean we have a country
of morbidly obese fentanyl addicts and
child nazis
that's our country like prepubescent
nazis
morbidly obese fentanyl addicts
and like like like
so in our country when you think of the
configurations in which people find and
love each other you have the uh
teacher student
you have the
uh
powerful business guy
uh
perhaps underage prostitute
you have
maybe two closeted nazis that are
[ __ ]
whatever but
what really encapsulates it because we
so many people in america are in uh jail
in prison so many
and there should be more no
so many people
are in prison and are incarcerated for
all manner of different things for
non-violent drug offenses for very
violent offenses
and they're in prison and then we have
corrections officers who are essentially
criminals corrections officers and
criminals there's very little difference
but no this is true
there's very little difference between
corrections officers and criminals most
people that get into corrections are
criminals or would have been criminals
or are criminals they run like teen
fight clubs in the jails they
uh they sneak in drugs and stuff it's
their oh they're they're like
prostitutes too they [ __ ] up yeah they
[ __ ] them and everything and i have no
issue with all that but whatever it gets
you through the day it makes everybody
happy i believe in communities
i believe in communities i love that
uh
so
this is a great story about a female
corrections officer right
who fell in love with the guy who's uh
they're trying to get him for murder
yeah yeah
yeah pin him they're trying to pin him
another innocent john
is this the woman that spent like she
like sold her home and used the money to
bail him
story about a jailhouse romance that
ended in death a veteran corrections
officer apparently fell in love with an
inmate and helped him escape with her so
that
that the two of them could run off
together
it happened at the lauderdale county
jail in alabama authorities say the
38-year-old inmate casey white who was
awaiting trial on murder struck up a
relationship with 56-year-old vicki
white no relation she was the assistant
director of corrections at the jail
where he was incarcerated her co-workers
described her as an exemplary employee
but that's why you say she planned how
to get casey out here by the way let's
make a point that is an exemplary
employee if you're a corrections officer
yeah
breaking them out of jail and [ __ ]
them
that like that is an exemplary employee
because here's the deal you're around
them all the time you're gonna fall in
love with them
yeah it's true you're gonna fall in love
with these p look at this guy you're
telling me you're not gonna fall in love
with this guy neanderthal jon hamm
the fact that this guy murdered somebody
turns you on it makes you hot
you know this guy killed someone
and and i lock his cage every night and
i let him out man what a fantasy
i lock his cage and then i let him out
it's hot
and she lives in alabama and she looks
like she's like an albino [ __ ] you
know
i don't know mole rat
[Laughter]
we all have to pretend like al yeah
because all these political people now
have to pretend that like new york and
l.a suck because they
listen we all know taxes are high and
like liberals can be crazy like
everybody has to pretend like that's
what america is about it's like alabama
everybody has to pretend that they're
like i won't live in missouri
it was hearing
i said guys you realize
bill maher did a great joke years ago he
said it it wasn't new york in l.a the
country would have been sold to china
years ago
like there is no but everybody has to
pretend like politically i've never been
to a place and went you know what i love
here the political uh outlook
i've never looked at an ocean and went i
love the taxes here
just allow yourself to have another
experience on the planet you [ __ ]
monkeys
but people can't do it right they can't
so they everything's political i don't
say austin's a [ __ ] because it's a
blue city in a red state or a purple i
say it's a shittle because it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] it's hot it's
muggy there's bugs the food's gross the
rivers are [ __ ] they're brown they look
like literal [ __ ] they're disgusting the
people are disgusting they're
unaccomplished they're idiots that's why
i say [ __ ] there's nothing to do with
the politics i don't know what the laws
are i don't care dump
i go to santa barbara i go it's pretty
but yeah there's homeless to the laws or
nuts and the people that run it are
[ __ ] psychopaths it doesn't mean it
ain't a better place to live all things
being equal
like if we let's say you gave taxes in
florida a state tax and a hefty one
you know how many people really love it
how many people are down there with
[ __ ] cowboy hats and boots like yeah
[Applause]
if you love it like let's see if you
would pay for it you wouldn't pay for it
right no there's nothing to pay for it
might listen with all the respect i like
dallas i like some places great
audiences but you go around austin you
go yeah i wouldn't pay a state tax to
live here why would i why would anyone
why would anyone pay estate tax so they
could take the boat out on the [ __ ]
river
it's gross
and i'm sorry
palm beach isn't palm beach doesn't have
a state tax either malibu is is kind of
a dump but it's better than austin the
the hamptons better than austin
lake lanier in georgia better than
austin
charlotte
charleston south carolina better you
know i don't know i don't know if
charleston's a democratic city or
republican city i don't care
doesn't mean anything to me but people
right now are so invested in politics
because it gives their meaningless lives
some type of like shape that they can
understand like you're good
because they have nothing going on in
their [ __ ] lives
and i understand that there's real
concerns and now they're trying to
get rid of roe v wade and [ __ ] like that
i'm not saying it's completely
unimportant but to make it this entire
thing where
you have to lie to yourself and start
saying that like
lake austin's nice can you get get up
lake austin and we'll get back to these
two retards
but get up a photo of lake austin get up
a photo of lake
and hit image
go to the right right there there it is
it's a level from donkey kong
that is a level from donkey kong it is
slime it's green slime from donkey kong
now get up a picture of malibu
california
and i i i don't like kevin newsom but
just get a picture of mount blue
california
it's better
don't you get that it's it's better
that's nicer and that ain't even that
nice
malibu ain't even that great it's not
even that good but it's better than that
swamp where i can shoot maggots in here
[Applause]
[Music]
so whatever but
there's nothing in malibu that looks
like that they just lie with some [ __ ]
too yeah it doesn't look like that
another [ __ ] it doesn't look like
that's like italy
but the point is it's a nicer dump
everything on earth is a dump we just
went to the rain forest it's fake
the great barrier reef doesn't exist we
put cigarettes out on it it's a
everything's a dump
but my point is don't get with no with
the politics it annoys me when you have
to start lying you start to start lying
and be like
i love you and these are people from the
northeast or from the west coast and
they go down there and they're like
[Applause]
all these tech demons these autistic
[ __ ] blinking tech [ __ ] and
they're like
[Music]
it's [ __ ]
grotesque
whatever we have fans there it's a nice
place
let's finish up these two retards
she even sold her home and announced her
retirement beforehand then on april 29
authorities say vicki picked up casey
from the jail for what she said was a
mental health evaluation which
authorities later learned was never even
scheduled the two of them fled in her
patrol car
vicky had spent the night before in a
motel near the jail authorities say she
bought men's clothing from a department
store beforehand so that casey would
have something to change into nice after
they left the jail the two of them
ditched her patrol car in a parking lot
where cops later found her jail keys a
radio and handcuffs
then they went on the run for 11 days
on next
the manager of a car wash in evansville
indiana had spotted casey on
surveillance video why are they washing
a car
oh good question how stupid are you
why are you washing your car they're
like we don't want people to think we're
dirty
why are you washing or is he maybe he's
hanging out there to rob people like
why are you you're on the run
where are they running where's the
destination who knows but why would you
stop in a car wash
i don't know yeah maybe they think they
run they were getting tailed so they
pulled in or something i don't know well
let's finish it all right here we go
they called federal authorities
u.s marshals service called me that's
right they sent me a text message from
alabama
this is this guy
when tech guys moved to austin texas
that all went to stamford this is what
they sound like
after three months in austin keep going
truck
toad i said i did i said that's a guy
from alabama he said yes it is
so he said i got us monsters coming to
you even as i speak cops located the
pair pretty quickly and saw vicki
walking out of a motel with a wig on
then they chased the pair down the
pursuit ended with the police crashing
into their getaway car they were able to
pull casey out of the wreckage but they
say vicki was critically hurt she had
shot herself in the head she later died
at the hospital
as for casey soon he'll be on his way
back to alabama
[Music]
as the twilight's last streaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the
perilous night
gave proof i don't even know if i'm
doing this right
that our flag was still there
and the rock is red glare
vicky's head bursting in there
gave proof through the night i mean what
a beautiful story
victor shot herself in the head she got
a wee she got a week of that good dick
what a whirlwind for the convict he's
just being taken back to prison like
well that was weird
[Music]
she's just killed herself
but here's the deal it's true love and
when you know it you know it right folks
i mean when you know it you know it and
when it hits you you don't always choose
you don't always choose it
she found someone that that loved her
and saw her for her
yeah and
he was a murderer
and she ended up being a murderer she
killed herself
isn't that fun
but it's an american story they should
make that a film yeah that should be a
film yeah you know yeah like somebody
that loves that deeply where they go i'm
just gonna blow my brains out because i
can't face the thought of everyone at
the old job where i had authority being
like what the [ __ ] you because she
turned on her family yeah you know
it's not like la where by doing that
you're rewarded with houses and pools
and tennis courts
they're in [ __ ] canvil the only thing
this woman has is those those other
mongoloids that she works with and they
all drink coffee together and they beat
the inmates and they lock them up
and that's what she does and she turned
on them by taking one of these inmates
out
escaping
putting the rest of the cops in danger
and
wouldn't it be funny if they didn't even
[ __ ] she's like i'm waiting for marriage
he's like we gotta fox you and i'm
telling you they're gonna get us and
she's like no
we're gonna live we got our whole lives
wouldn't it be funny if that was her
attitude she's like we got our whole
lives for this he's like i don't think
so
he's like please let's just [ __ ]
she's like we got her hold up she's
picking she's on zillow she's like what
can we afford he's like listen
i think you're underestimating how deep
of [ __ ] we're in they're gonna come get
us and i'm going back to jail
it says here i can get approved for 185
000
with a downpipe now you can't go on the
loan of course but with a down payment i
can get something nice we can get a
double wide
man you know what's nice i hear is
austin texas
cause joe rogan
he's opening a comedy club down there in
austin texas and elon musk's gonna let
us say hard r on twitter
so let's go to texas and he's like honey
i think we're going to get shot some guy
made me at the [ __ ] car wash
well
that's where i washed my [ __ ]
you really should have done kill tony
tonight yeah wearing a lot of [ __ ]
i thought you were funny your minute was
good
honey you made me do that i tend to
think that really that that really
exposed us nah you were good
uh but it's an american it's a beautiful
american love story
and there's not much like that anymore
and you know it's it's uh that intensity
of love no it'll be a mini series soon
it should be right on hulu someone else
kind of like salmon louise a little bit
yeah a little bit bonnie and clyde
especially at transcen's age she was 56
he was 38. yeah but they're going to
give it it's going to be hot people it
needs to be yeah it'll be charlize their
own no it needs to be gross people where
the sex scenes make you go ugh
but it should be like really gross like
that's what
movies need like gross sex scenes again
where like it's just real animalistic
disgusting
like she has an open wound yeah you know
and it smells because it's moldy
and you could tell like he's flinching
as he enters her
and she's like and she makes this little
sound like
[Music]
they did that in truth she's got a light
parking sensor she shakes as he does it
she's like
[Music]
that's what it should be
and and then like the last scene in the
movie he's like they're [ __ ] getting
us he's like i'll always love you and he
goes in for a kiss and before before he
gets to her she goes like this she goes
you know
you know and then they're like
dedicated to the legacy of the civil
rights march
like something that has nothing to do
something has nothing to do with
anything
you know
[Music]
produced by colin kaepernick
produced by the obamas yeah
uh no dates no merch nothing to see here
go away kill it kill kill kill kill
yourselves
vicky white this is the story of vicki
why
people are losing their hair and you got
to fight it but the way to fight it is
before you have lost it that's why you
got to go to keeps if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash jim dillon they
have convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home 27 uh
24 7 care and support keeps as a network
of expert medical advisors prescribers
and care specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality i mean
keep says more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors and i'm telling
you right now
prevention is key treatments can take up
to 46 months to see results so act fast
when it comes to your health save more
and spend less if you're ready to take
action and really get serious about
preventing your hair from going away
to receive your first month of treatment
for free
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon first
month of treatment for what
for free what
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim
dillon tell you a story about keeps
because uh this is something that a lot
of people don't know a good friend of
mine was felt like his hair was falling
out he said to me he goes what's going
on
he goes i wake up sometimes it's in the
bed and stuff like that and i said to
him i said why don't you
try keeps
and he did
and he's doing it now with a full head
of hair go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dillon
youtube devin costa
uh you can follow these guys on twitter
uh ida tavakoli what's your tweet
twitter handle
at
ida tabitholi at either table
subscribe to his youtube channel he
makes really really funny uh videos we
should make videos again but we just
aren't going to
you know we're just not i'm just not
going to dress up like a hand sanitizer
or anything anymore i used to
i just can't do it i used to but i can't
i'm 37 or i'm 36 i don't know what i am
but the point is i'm too old i'm really
too old to be like running around
dressed up like a crab you know like
what a crab say
what a crabs do although crab that's not
woke anymore whatever like i ca i'm too
old i'm like old
that's what i used to do i used to do
like funny videos and cos i used to put
on wigs and dress like women and [ __ ]
i dress like a corona ball i'd have
people make foam costumes epstein's
temple and they were really fun because
it was great they were phenomenal yeah
they were fun but you grow out you just
like you
level up just make
a bigger thing we did we did and we will
it's just bigger things cost money you
gotta have good good ideas so if you're
gonna put the money behind it you gotta
have an idea
so like you know we we used to lampoon a
lot of like crazy stuff and wall culture
and stuff and and
even right wing culture we would just
lampoon the insanity of everything going
on
uh and you know there are ways that we
still think about doing that but it just
gets i don't know it gets more and more
uh difficult and i think the main focus
is building out the show i think we
eventually wanted like musical guests so
it's like a real late night show
like who would be our first musical
guest do you think ben like would be
really that we could get like who could
we actually get who could we actually
get uh the guy from uh that really big
band the lumineers is a big fan okay
well
little xander i don't i don't know
anything about the luminous i'm sure
they're great they're they're a huge
band but i don't think we can get them
as my point what about future
oh yeah i don't know yeah it was huge
they're two these people are too big i
mean it's one thing to be a fan or maybe
like something that i do it's another
thing to commit to showing up and doing
it
yes more latoya
one more weekend in the city
she's uh
a musician that we saw
her name on it
on a marquee in l.a we just started
following her
and we're following her
musical career ladies and gentlemen and
she's got a really good song can we play
her song no no why because we'll just
lose she'll get all the money from this
episode
get her off get her face out of here
taking my [ __ ] money
done enough for her by mentioning her
name
but she's got like a one catchy song we
don't know any other ones no no no and
and the song the chorus is the good part
yeah i mean listen she's not you know
she's not joni mitchell
thank god huh yeah
musical spotify
model the torpos musical spotify dude
what if comedian like what if musicians
started doing it now like get us all
over
would just be so funny if like big
musicians on spotify are like i am
taking a stand
i'm pulling my music off spotify
mackenzie phillips takes a stand yeah
someone takes a stand yeah like ariana
grande ariana grande is like i'm pulling
my music off
spotify and then she says it in spanish
spanish yeah isn't she spanish no she's
i don't know what she is uh she's a
sicilian and like italian yeah she's
white with a spray tan but she is
italian too
she's great i mean she's beautiful but
yeah she's very attractive she looks
pretty bad without makeup actually no
she doesn't she looks great i'm sure
she's fine
let's see a photo of her okay
she's very attractive she's beautiful
you know i don't know it's you know yeah
great spray i mean go to the without
makeup
ben
this one here is everything that's what
she's like
good i think they're cheaters no they're
not everyone's cheating i think she
looks fine there she looks good she
looks good
but i understand you but they shouldn't
they should be made up right i mean
isn't that the point but yeah well we
call them like this you know but you
know what it is
it's not only just makeup it's like a
lot of people are doing fillers
injections of plastic surgery the fake
ass is the new head the woman from a
million dollar list got a new head
no tracy tudor got a new head
and i think that's good
if i had money i'd get a new head find
money like that tracy tutor go go go go
look she's got a new head
this woman's head's completely new
she had one head she got a new hat yeah
because this was her right yeah that was
her that go to the other side i really
don't see them no this is oh it's
totally different i got a new head you
said this and i like it
what is that different about it what do
you mean the head
i bit her head
it's like chloe cardero she got a new
head
yeah that is a new head she got her nose
done that's you know i'm not saying
you're getting more than that it's more
than that it's like chin and shed it's
[ __ ] listen if you're going to be on
television you're a huge proponent of
plastic surgery no i mean i've never
gotten plastic surgery but i think if
you know you can afford it and it makes
it i'm not saying it's a bad thing it
makes you feel bad as if as long as it's
not like you know
as long as it's tasteful and what's it
what's up what's bad plastic surgery oh
i mean god there's you can see it huh
yeah a bad hack job of course yeah i
mean and and it yeah it's all over la
it's everywhere
no to everyone you're also an expert in
brazilian uh butt lift uh bbl i'm not
but i've i've looked into denying what
you know about well i know that i okay i
know two things i know that there's two
different kinds of bbls and one of them
is invasive and one of them is
non-invasive can you show that arielle
the man with the
house oh yeah what's his name
i'm a huge fan of mario
that's great listen
i think everyone should be able to do
kind of everything yeah yeah pretty much
what they want his ass looks better than
any others
honestly because mostly it's women
mostly it's women that get the new ass
but i kind of want an ass and i might
buy an ass you should i [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of this guy i might buy ben and ass
would your wife mind if i got you an ass
uh it's for the show right i can get it
taken out later
no it's invasive it depends what kind
you get
so i can't get it like cut off later
cut off you amputate your deflated i
think jesus no you uh you would your
wife's gonna have to understand that the
show is the primary yeah and if you had
a luscious ass you'd be nothing wrong
with that ben you deserve enough show
just evolves into you deforming ben
i go like this i'm like i'm sick of
dressing up in costumes so i'm gonna
give ben an ass
um
no you are
you are you said there's two there's the
invasive one yeah there's an invasive
one i think the other one they just put
i think they just put fillers in
versus
but i don't know what an implant is go
to a bbl problem ben okay they're like
bbl like when things go real bad for the
bb else
because occasionally
you know one cheek is it explodes it
explodes it works harder than the other
okay is that i haven't seen that you can
get scarring so this says influencer
devastated by drooping bum and lumpy leg
so if you can see here it has one of the
highest death rates of all surgeries i
think especially because people don't uh
always get it in a reputable place no
they go to like mexico or whatever these
are taking over cities if you walk
around cities oh yeah yeah they're
everywhere people love this just walk
around glendale it's like
let me ask you a question is it harmful
if your ass explodes
i don't think so i think it's as long as
it's uh
no i don't i imagine it's not great i
imagine it's not great like are you
if a silicone implant explodes in your
ass you're probably at some type of
health risk well i don't think it's
silicone oh
i don't know no no no you know what it
is fat they take it's it's lipo so they
take the fat out of all the other parts
of your body like full body lipo and
then they put that into your ass does it
need to be your fat
i think if you want i i don't i think
because what i'm wondering is why don't
they just harvest fat people and get
their fat and then use it like a sperm
baby yeah because we have a huge problem
in this country obesity is an issue yes
we also have the fact that the bbls are
too expensive
and doesn't it doesn't it get better if
we started using like if you take a fat
person take all their fat
and redistribute it to the ass of uh an
inspiring instagram model yeah fat
redistribution a brazilian butt lift
involves three basic steps fat is
removed from the hips lower back thighs
abdomen and or areas with liposuction
the extracted fat is purified and
prepared for transfer
what a job i'm purifying the fat
the cosmetic surgeon injects fat into
specific points on the buttocks to
increase volume and improve
improve shape
what did the kardashians have done they
had the best tell us about their doctor
is the best i don't know i i really
don't know i genuinely don't know what
they've done they all naturally seem to
have some
like
are they already have like asses kim got
too much done it looks like really
don't they have a special doctor
probably what do you mean probably don't
you know who it is no i mean everybody i
think speculates but i don't know
are you afraid is she like afraid are
you afraid no i don't know i'm like all
she talks about every day and then every
single day she talks with it's very
interesting well here's the thing this
is what they do they promote certain
doctors do they go to those doctors i
don't know but they promote them on
their instagrams so it's hard for me to
say that they go is this like because
they kind of look like you do you have
like some weird code where you can't
it's an omerta you can't you can't you
can't talk about like ass issues no
listen i would talk about it i just yeah
okay so simon orion he
and then there's dr govany they both
your people
yes yeah
um
actually um nicole benham is his niece
oh the girl from clubhouse yeah yeah um
i don't want to hear the word clubhouse
again in my [ __ ] life
it's just 15 year old venture capitalist
criminals
yeah well so it's over man was i wrong
about that god so wrong but it was fun
for like a minute it was fun for like a
month
uh but yeah i don't know so i don't know
if they've ever gone to those doctors
for any sort of surgery but i know that
they isn't interesting kim kardashian is
a very
fascinating person yes
she's like a businesswoman she's
incredibly smart savvy swift shrewd like
she's able to kind of
really
position herself in this way that has
made her one of the most famous people
in the world but you're also like you
know in a different
world or timeline or whatever you want
to call it she's like a rich wife
that lives in like glendale
you know what do you mean meaning that
like
it's such a
interesting confluence of events
that happened
and it's such an interesting thing that
they were able to capitalize on those in
the way that they did repeatedly over
and over again
uh up until the point they were all
billionaires and all famous i mean the
hilton's tried this
yeah paris hilton tried this right
he had people like lindsay lohan uh the
other person uh uh
lionel richie's daughter uh
i mean we grew up with like these
tabloid types of people there were even
more people than that
nobody no one got to this point come
close
to the massive empire these people have
built it's remarkable it's it's
completely is it chris is it the mom
yeah i think she's the i think she's
ultimately the glue to all of it because
i think she keeps everyone in check like
she does why do you laugh when she said
she's she's the yeah she's the mom that
releases her daughter's sex tape
she's a great great can i play devil's
patreon you know what i'd give for my
mom to release my sex tape you know
my mom keeps watching mine
let me play double santa let me play
devil's advocate on this because i've
heard a lot of hubbub about this i love
that word your daughter is a sex tape
with a guy
let me tell me tell me you have a
daughter
because you ida doesn't want to have
kids you have a daughter okay
okay she has a sex tape
okay
with a
well-known guy
oh it's my daughter how old was kim
uh
20
something 26 25 i don't know he's 27.
12. no she's one she's an adult
27.
you watch the sex tape
how old was she uh 23 23. okay and you
see this you see the sex tape that your
daughter has with
this person and it's good
and you're you can say that
no you can say that objectively oh it's
great it's really good like you can say
that objectively you can go you know i
don't love watching this it doesn't make
me happy to watch it but it is a good
sex tape it's not it's a bad sex is it
yeah it sucks you don't barely see
anything we all jacked off to it back in
the day in high school and stuff and it
was like bad but it was maybe good for
the era it was good for the time sure
yeah yeah
it was like acoustic it was good
was it because your daughter ben's
daughter will have to do [ __ ] it'll have
to be so high-definition it'll have to
be so hardcore it'll have to be so
different now for him to say it's worth
releasing right like he'll really have
to see his daughter his daughter taking
it's just going to be
you know really up close like you know
really really good right she has to be
raped by a villain you see that and you
see her way out
you see your way out of a humdrum
housewife life like you've had for the
most of your life chris jenner i i'm the
plus one i'm the friend of uh my friend
you know when you go well there's a few
ways you can go when you're a housewife
right you could be the plus one forever
you could just go to the country club or
you could get decapitated by a
psychopath like my friend nicole brown
simpson the wife of a housewife maybe
not that glamorous in brentwood right
kris jenner goes
you got to remember kris jenner watched
her friend get decapitated
um not literally but maybe you know who
knows uh
this probably
lights a fire under her ass a little bit
and goes
women
have to be more powerful yeah and not
rely on men
her husband dies right ex-husband yeah
they were divorced at that point but
yeah right
she basically says to herself
women
maybe need to be powerful what is the
way
what is a way to kind of jump start my
daughter's career and i don't know if
she did or did not release the tape but
she releases the tape um
and she thinks to herself
you know you wonder if kris jenner
before she release releases that grainy
footage of of kim
she might say to herself you know one
day
we're all gonna be billionaires
you know like does does a woman like
that sure have some kind of weird
thought where she goes listen i see the
way the culture is going i see the way
things are happening i see what's going
on i watched the o.j simpson trial the
beginning of reality tv
i watched the way tabloids have taken
over i watched the way that has seeped
into every aspect of our culture and i
know that if my daughter is to have a
shot if my family is to have a shot we
need to jump start this light of fire
you release the tape and
how many years later 20 years later uh
yeah about 19 yeah they have an empire
19 years later they are the most famous
people on earth they have an empire they
are billionaires
they can do whatever they want they can
try to cure diseases if they want i
don't know that that's what they're
doing but they could if they want
is it
worth it
if that comes out of it well here's
what's great about them though they
don't
they did kim uh actually exonerated like
a set they've done more for people i
think and on a material prison there are
so many people in our country
who release footage of their children
having sex on the dark web
and get nothing out of it not a perfume
line
not a [ __ ] deal at e
not a [ __ ] right no yeah you're right
it's a great point yeah um and they did
they did it all they did that yeah
certainly cosmetics lines
everything everything you can imagine
they can walk into any oval office
probably at this point get a meeting age
what do you think happens when they're
older
like in the future what's going to
happen yeah because i've got a
prediction but i want to hear yours oh
okay well um i think they'll age
gracefully and probably get a facelift
or two but as expected but but yeah
probably what are you saying
i think they might go uh some sort of
political route politics that's what i
think yeah wouldn't be the worst idea i
believe that i believe they'll go
politics you think so yes no i think
they want to just go straight capitalist
and just
i think there's a bunch of them
there's a bunch of them yeah well
i think who's gonna go for politics um
rob
no of course not i truly i believe he
i'm gonna say this and i'm i'm not even
kidding right now i'm not kidding
i don't think kim kardashian would be
the worst governor of california no not
at all i i truly believe that not at all
i believe she'd be better than gavin
newsom i believe kim kardashian might be
a better governor than gavin newsom she
she's pragmatic and she understands what
people want
or want she understands people need that
bling yeah no she understands she's uh
she's more connected to everybody people
need
people need that [ __ ]
appletini in the
fall people need to get their paper
they need to eat tuna tartare with
wontons
they need to go out
to do like a white party every now and
then a hookah bar
you know the piglets need little treats
piglets need little treats
and she is she the worst governor of
california is kim kardashian the worst
governor of california no no i don't
think so
the best i mean
probably not i could see it i mean
does it even matter
it doesn't even matter i think it does i
think it does i think it does and i'll
tell you why
i think
number one here's what i think is
interesting caitlyn is is his totally
unserious attempt i think kim's watching
that and going you know i could do this
for real
oh you think that's maybe why the law
but the new interest in law you think is
because of an eventual
i think she's going how much longer am i
going to be a reality she's a
billionaire already she's a billionaire
many times over she will be yeah where
where where is there to go yeah it's
it's where is there to go how else do
you expand your influence where is there
to go other than you have the money now
you kind of want the power
i think there's a very good chance that
one day and it's kim i think it's kim
kim is it kim yeah um
or chris
no no no yeah kim has a unique
blend of pragmatism
uh you could already see she's like you
know women need to go out and work and
then people like it's insensitive but a
lot of people going
hmm you know what
i like hearing that yeah
i like hearing that
when when when she gets out there and
revs him up
i like that i let me tell you right now
man
i've become a massive fan of her
once she started telling these fat slobs
in this country to go to work
yeah i mean really they don't give
handouts ida had the show on one time
and they like they have like a homeless
friend there's like a homeless guy that
the whole family like hung out with 10
years ago so they had him back at the
house and they didn't give him anything
they just were like no they did they
gave him an apartment oh really
for like a month or something find that
now ben ben find it now they were just
like watching them eat catch up and be
like oh you love names shorty his name
is shorty sure okay i can't play clips
but we can we can read this here khloe
kardashian showed her charitable side on
the latest episode of keeping up with
the kardashians as she reconnected with
her homeless friend the reality is i
mean by the way
i mean just
he was pretty seasonal give it to me in
the veins
put it in my veins right now
i can't they are the they are
they are they have met the moment they
are meeting
the moment they are the moment they are
the moment
the reality star 36 first met shoddy
in the first season of the show now that
the program is continuing to an end or
coming to an end she instilled some
nostalgia viewers by reaching out and
recruiting her family to help secure him
an apartment
so she met shorty in the first season of
the show how long has the show gone on
oh let's see
uh 13 years after first meeting in
season one so so shorty yeah
was he homeless in season one uh yeah i
think so so sure it was season one so
shorty's had a rough thirteen
and now they've decided they have enough
money because they don't want to start
helping because you got you know it's
like it's like the airplane you you put
the mask on yourself before you help
another so they've decided now at like i
don't know their combined net worth of
eight billion dollars they can buy
shorty department
after chloe discovered from word of
mouth that shorty was working at flips
coin laundry in los angeles
she went in search of her friend yet the
attempt was fruitless before producers
helped or track him down in scene shot
last year
are we to believe that chloe went to the
i think someone laundry
or she contacted the producers
in episode seven of series one entitled
helping hand chloe welcomed shorty into
their home after she found him outside
of their dash door in 2007.
this the sisters then got shorty cleaned
up bought him new clothes fixed his
teeth gave him a haircut
before they lost touch they did all they
cleaned up gave him a makeover yeah and
then put him back out on the street
which they have to what are they gonna
do
what is shorty gonna be one of the
kardashians this is shorty kardashian
the family has not seen shorty for 13
years
it's been a bit
chloe had constantly been tweeted by
viewers asking what happened to him
whether he was
can you imagine that she's sitting like
a bubble bag
she's like answering she's on like a
call
with like some marketing company you
know trying to figure out
how to make like uh you know some type
of tampon that they're gonna sling
to people and like somebody tweets her
hey remember shorty is he alive
fans even tagged chloe in pictures of
shorty when they saw him on the street
[Music]
and sad she wanted to see if he was
doing well i like the idea that he
becomes a member of the family they give
him a fake ass they make them all hot i
like the idea oh look at him look at
shorty there he is i like the idea of
them
taking a photo tagging him going hey
remember shorty
like they're billionaires they go
remember but what are they supposed to
give a [ __ ] are you supposed to care
about this guy he was outside their
store what what movie landscape world do
people live in
what what are you
what are they supposed to what do you
think she's gonna do with the apartment
i'm not saying they shouldn't give it to
him what do you think shorty's gonna do
with the apartment after 13 years on the
street
i mean you know he'll do heroin safely
yeah
over his head
when he so
the pair drove around getting more tips
about shorting giving chloe's number to
a guy who claimed to know him soon
shorty was facetiming chloe at her home
and being invited for lunch the next day
it'd be great if you like came over and
he's like there's pedophiles underground
have you heard about q anon
he's like
he's probably a fed
when he showed up shorty told chloe kim
and courtney that he'd been working at
flips but it had closed due to covet so
now go down
go up there that's a rough uh
look
he looks worse cleaned up yeah kind of
sisters then got shorty cleaned up
brought him your clothes fixed his teeth
give me her
okay that's him now
yeah shorty
oh shorty
he's searching for a job and apartment
he added chris facetime shorty and put
kylie jenner on camera reminding him she
was a little girl when they first met
little that's no little girl shorty
observed you know you observed her it
groped
that's no little girl
the things i do to her
the kardashians later secured a rent
control department for shorty hoping to
help him become more independent god
does wonders short he said thankful that
he never met the family
um
that's it
we just take their word for it
what did they got him an apartment yeah
i
mean
it's not that official savings yeah at
least [ __ ] up or something where's
shorty spin-off
it'll probably be on true tv
have you seen any of their new show on
hulu i've seen one episode yeah the
first episode what do you think about it
um
it's good
it's elevated
elevated version i think of the e and
what
why would you say it's elevated explain
to us what that means because they're
billionaires and
it shows in the production value uh
it's they're just the most powerful
force i think in in this city and
certainly in the country and that's
brilliant
completely out of her mind i can't i ca
i can't because she just goes again she
says things like that at dinner she goes
they're the most powerful fish
in the world i've never meant anything
more i really have i mean i'm not what
fascinates you so much let me just have
a cigarette i'm quitting smoking cause i
bought a new car this is a great way to
start no because i ha i have i and
everyone everyone doubts me but they're
lying you got a cheap wrangler
what did you bring you bought a jeep
wrangler uh what fascinates me about
them we're not gonna say the cardboard
but it's so funny that you knew i didn't
buy a jeep it's a jeep wrangler you knew
it wasn't a jeep wrangler i'm not going
to say what it is i've been trying to
help yeah it's i know i knew
i thought like i wouldn't
yeah
can't fool me
no i knew
i knew um did you know i was gonna get
it when we went to look at it yeah
absolutely
you didn't know yeah i did how uh i
remember you uh when we when you used to
live in agora hills i remember you
calling that specific dealership that
will not be named in agora
so i knew you you had an interest about
it
uh but you had a you had a thing about
you we hadn't slept in a long time i
knew there was no way you weren't
walking out of there without the car
it wasn't like you were just bored i
haven't slept in 48 hours because of
australia i'm still [ __ ]
louis gomez is staying at my house
yeah
so
let's get back to
what what did i ask her before we left
uh what she
uh thought about uh do you even pay
attention to the show
are you just watching like golf matches
in your own head do you even pay
attention to what we're doing here
i mean it's honestly so what ida said is
she said they're the most powerful force
in the country and you kind of wanted
her to extrapolate that and then you
went on to the car thing what is it
about yeah it's my fault that's the way
he lays down and then you went on well i
don't know which thing you want to go
back to because she didn't really answer
that question what is it about them
particularly that really fascinates you
to no end
i think they've um
really intelligently utilized every tool
that's been given to them in a way that
absolutely that perhaps others wouldn't
and haven't but also they look like you
you have a very similar look to that i
mean that's a great compliment to me
yeah no that's true
if they were five irish women
with red hair and freckles with the same
kind of power would you care i would
scoff at them yeah you would i would
scoff at them no yeah certainly there's
a try but here's the thing before i was
not a big fan because i thought they
were misrepresented reinhardt pull up
the woman that i am obsessed with from
australia she could buy and sell the
kardashians pull up big gina
pull up my girl
pull a big
oh boy who is she
she's the rich she's the world's yeah
yeah yeah she's [ __ ] [ __ ] with iron
ore
what did her dad mining lang hancock
they discovered the mods in australia
she's a gangster boy could she use the
kardashians
they could use her they haven't gotten
their hands on some minds
that's the next things they they should
start doing is mining
yeah i mean yeah they probably will
20 years from now like 10 years from now
they have a special they're like
remember blue gloop the minor that chloe
met in the first season of the
kardashian mods
well he's
since lost his arm and foot but people
were tagging photos of him dragging
himself in the dirt village where he
lived and chloe went and bought him
water
they got reunited
they that's the next thing they should
get into is the just total domination of
natural resources well they'll probably
go into renewal
renewable energy that's their audience
and their forward thinking what do you
mean that's their own
audience
that's their audience tim perhaps people
that care about green energy well their
audience is so expansive it's it's so
big is it it is yeah look at their
instagram following alone it's it's
unbelievable is it bigger than mine
i mean do you have 278 million followers
on instagram
i don't know i think i have followers
that aren't you might have better
engagement no i don't
i don't want the engagement leave me
alone
uh but i'll tell you right now uh
they are it's just they're uniquely
american fascinating group of people and
my fans some of my fans probably hate
this because they're like
you should be i used to think that way i
used to think you should be [ __ ] on
them because that's your job to [ __ ] on
them just [ __ ] on everybody it's like
maybe not maybe i want to ride to the
moon with them on a nuke
i don't want to hang out with people
that care about stand-up comedy so god
damn much
rich people don't care about stand-up
comedy at all like real rich when you
meet real rich people no they just don't
give a [ __ ] about any of the they just
they're like yeah let the clowns do it
who gives a [ __ ] about them
do whatever they want but no they they
interest me a lot it's interesting you
think they heard pete it's gonna last
i have no opinion on that okay
i have no idea
i'm trying to get some i feel like i've
got to understand here
i feel like i've got you on the stage
you have no opinion what do you mean you
have no i don't know
no opinion on that you've studied them
like a course in school it's been a
reason because here's the thing i used
to doubt them and and and make fun of
them like everybody else until i
realized like oh no no no no these
people are like like it's something
something hit where i like suddenly
the light switch went off i was like oh
she's the person figured out we all have
a person we want to have a lunch with
she's up there
who else would even be close in your
book dead or alive or
alive ida a lot i mean i don't know
[Music]
um
yeah she's probably
on the spot i can't even think of
anybody but yeah she's like donald
rumsfeld yeah kim kardashian well he's
dead he's dead
yeah
spelled in kim kardashian what do you
think that's what her would be like if
she was really honest here's the thing
with these people yeah they're always a
brand uh whatever right so like their
brand they're always conscious of how
they come off
what do you think a real honest lunch
with her would be like if you sat down
with her and you were and she was honest
with you about everything
i don't think she
did she possessed the ability to be
like she gets a little soft
like no she doesn't drink really she
doesn't drink but like do you think
she'll just do you think she looks at
you during that lunch and goes i own the
world
i would hope that's why i want the lunch
i own the world ida
do you think she looks and goes
the people
are nothing without me like what do you
think they what is their family backdoor
sessions like
i mean
no but the mystique is what is when i
wrote a thing about them
i wrote that the hilton
get the thing i'm going to find the
thing that i wrote
about them i wrote something kind of
brilliant about it and see it's their
reputations evolved over time so i
wonder what how long ago this was that
you wrote this
i'm telling lewis to come
what's the address here ben
uh well i'm not gonna say it on the show
but here just let me text it text him
i wrote a brilliant thing
i wrote something
i really have to go back to writing
these long-form things because
it's some of the best content that
facebook
has ever seen
i did my a lot of my best work on
facebook i agree it was before i knew
you i would read this and i you know and
i just wrote about
soup
and the kardashians sometimes and it was
now i sound i've become the brook and
connor show like i've literally become
it it's not a joke anymore
like like
facebook is like older
and like see if you could find
kardashians and hiltons please please
please please and we'll edit some of
this out if it's dead air but
see if you can do it uh kim kardashian
and i wrote about these two dynasties
and how these two dynasties because a
lot of people were writing about the
bushes and the clintons as dynasties
maureen dowd was writing about the
bushes and the clintons dynasties in new
york times she was obsessed with that
kind of shakespearean dynastic thing
and i started comparing the hiltons and
the kardashians
um and it was a longer form thing oh
yeah maybe that's it this thing about
bruce jenner
january 30th 2015.
no no that's not it hold on was it on
tumblr no
i didn't put it on tumblr
uh
yeah there it is right isn't that it
yeah
i think paris hilton's younger brother
conrad not the power bottom baron was
behaving like a lunatic on a flight and
had to be restrained the hiltons are
like a nightmare there's a reason the
kardashians are the first family of this
country they have it all they don't go
nuts on planes they get deweys like
normal people they have one a biracial
couple two a person in transition from a
man to a woman
uh three models four a world-class
athlete four a five a fat person but
never more than one at one time chloe
now rob
chris jenner is the original momager a
momager a bulldog who splits uh who
spins kids into gold the kardashians are
the perfect new money empire they're
connected to the worlds of hip-hop
sports reality tv in fashion the hiltons
are fading wasps of yesteryear living
off a fortune earned years before they
could snort it the hiltons are the worst
kind of white the kardashians fit
perfectly into the zeitgeist because
they helped create it i raised my glass
to them as you should and i mean it's
perfect it's perfectly stated it would
it would have been a shame if i answered
the question because that i couldn't
have said that nothing that's exactly oh
you couldn't have i couldn't have well
you know
i i i didn't really i didn't know we're
gonna do 40 minutes on a kardashian spot
yeah your fan face is going to hate me
for this
no they might hate me for it but the
reality is i think we got another hour
in us
of it i mean i could talk about them for
yeah
i think we got another two or three
hours in us of this yeah i love that
that'll be great let me tell you right
now one of the guests i'd love to see on
jre why does he not have kim
i was wondering why kim thanks for doing
this mom
[ __ ] your mom you were like [ __ ] it's
weird because you're famous
and you're very famous
isn't fame weird mom because
you know when you get famous people like
i'm i don't like being famous
and my friends don't like it either like
elon musk
they hate fame
and it's weird
but it's like this is you could only
like when you're famous like you're
famous you can only like relate other
famous people it gets weird
you you become like in this little
cocoon
of famous people and that's why i moved
to austin because
i can be around simple people like santa
bullock and matthew mcconaughey they're
because they're simple
farmers
they're farmers
and it's [ __ ] weird
are you vaccinated kim
[Laughter]
[Music]
brett weinstein just leering at her like
[Music]
tim millercomedy.com ladies and
gentlemen we all love you and we
appreciate you and we and we we
appreciate the people that watch this
show all the time we really do
and i know that
joe rogan revealed why he would have kim
kardashian on his podcast
oh
okay 2019. okay good well i'm glad the
door is open but we do appreciate
everybody who watches this show and uh
i would like to extend an invite to any
of the kardashians to come we could get
rob
yeah we want caitlyn but nell cat
caitlyn
you don't want caitlyn yeah we do
okay you don't want caitlyn bars no you
want caitlyn but you know if you could
have caitlin or i would rather kim of
course
of course
yeah i'd rather the one who was wasn't
exiled from the family
is she on is caitlyn on the new season
i have no idea i don't think so i think
i think that should we turn it into a
kardashians podcast
about the kardashians until we kill
ourselves
yeah i mean it's uh
it wouldn't be unprofitable i love ben
ben an hour and 40 minutes in has
decided to work she's not
caitlyn jenner says it's unfortunate
she's not involved in the garden it's
unfortunate it's sad
she'd love to go on rogan
caitlin's like tried to get on nine
times well wait why why doesn't he ever
i don't know
yeah why doesn't he ever maybe he's just
like what are we gonna
do what well when she comes on you gotta
treat her like a legitimate political
candidate like what are you gonna do oh
come on
she wouldn't
she wouldn't
look at herself that way right i mean
come on yeah she tried to run for
governor yeah i mean did she really try
like she knew that she left to do
celebrity big brother
it's not exactly commitment but it's not
exactly what we need in this state we
need somebody a little stronger exactly
will she keep running for governor you
think no it's over it was just a fun
thing she'll probably run over the next
governor she might hit the next governor
i think kim uh kim's the hope
yeah
kim might be the hope
it's really looking that way yeah
it i can't really think of anybody else
as i just said they're the most powerful
force in the world yeah well they've
bridged the gap between mainstream and
like independent success i think in a
unique way where they're doing their own
thing but they're accepted by all
mainstream institutions at the same time
so the there's it's really limitless
they're accepted by mainstream
institutions
yeah they are
okay
they like the met
like the met sure yeah yeah like
disney i mean they're they're with
disney now they're with yeah is there a
kardashian disney film one day
or it's just like a bunch of princesses
with big asses
who like help a homeless guy
we met a guy named shorty
and 13 years he struggled and then we
gave him our energy drink
we got to come up with a [ __ ] cool
energy drink yeah that's what's really
hurt this show logan paul has one nel
has a a hard sell sir
i need to come up with a toxic
like
brazilian coffee
that gives people like botulism and
kills them
what if we just started selling
tap water called tap
we need to really get involved with like
a very shady food and beverage packaging
company
and just like
start slinging [ __ ] and get the
kardashians involved they'll sling [ __ ]
yeah they'll sling it they'll slang it i
did have a caller devin costa
the always ungrateful and
vastly i mean just useless in a way
that's
shocking
stunning in in a way that's surprising
to me how out of it he is free ben how
truly out of it he uh free him freehand
he can go back to the pet store he used
to work at that's real freedom
dealing with comics it would come in and
talk about [ __ ] that cat
good night